[Music]
welcome back to the third episode of
exit strategy podcast with here with one
of my favorite founders her name's Cara
and she's the founder and CEO of hint
water Cara thanks so much for doing this
super excited job thanks for having me I
feel like you and I have met plenty of
times in the past but rarely we had an
opportunity to do it like an in-depth
one-on-one discussion so really excited
to do so just a quick background in the
history of hint water you guys started
in 20 2005 much like what you're
drinking right now you guys make a
flavored water that's generally flavored
with fruit the water is generally
non-carbonated although you have a
carbonated version there's no sugar
stevia calories artificial nerves in the
water dissolve that sound right am i
messing out
that's absolutely right we have over had
20 flavors of our water and and then a
few years ago we came out with a a
carbonated version and then a
caffeinated version of the product too
and so you started the business back in
2005 when you were making the switch
from Diet Coke because you just didn't
feel healthy drinking the 8 to 12 cans
that you were drinking is that right
yeah I just you know I I never realized
this about myself but I you know was
really I just I really just wasn't happy
with where I was at from a health
perspective and I had gained a few
pounds but I had also also developed
really bad adult acne which I had never
even had as a kid and I really felt like
my energy levels were low too and I
couldn't really figure out what was
going on and you know we were I was at a
time when I had taken I had had three
four kids now but I had three kids at
the time so I was taking a little break
from work I had left AOL where I was
running their e-commerce platform and I
just you know was interviewing for jobs
we were like we my husband and I were
redoing a house in San Francisco
and I just took the time to kind of you
know get in shape and it's funny I mean
I always tell people when I'm out
speaking about sort of my background
story I really thought I mean I probably
wouldn't have admitted it but I really
thought that my pathway to get healthy
was just shopping at Whole Foods like if
I went into Whole Foods and I went
shopping there that I was good to go
like I was like you know I was going to
be healthy and then I was like okay well
I'm not really getting any healthier
things aren't really changing for me and
I had been an athlete growing up I was a
gymnast and so I you know started I knew
how to train and so I thought okay I'm
really gonna start working out and
training and and you know continuing to
shop it and buy you know better for you
products but then nothing was still
working and so I ended up going to a few
different doctors who basically said you
know look you're probably having too
many cupcakes and I'm you know and
that's why you're getting all this
weight and that's where you're having
this problem with your skin our you know
hormones or you've had babies too close
to one another and none of it really
made sense to me so your response wasn't
like the cupcakes are from Whole Foods
that yeah no I really you know I said no
that's not really what's going on so
yeah at that point I I really started to
take a closer look and and you know
maybe one of the doctors said hey keep a
diary of everything that you're eating
and everything that you're doing and I
don't even think I really counted my
diet soda consumption because I didn't
really think of it as food I really
buted as just like something else that
I'm doing and and there's nothing wrong
with it so why count it but then one day
I was looking at the label on you know
his diet coke was my favorite but the
Pepsi people loved me because I always
talk about you know Diet Coke and and
yeah my problem with Diet Coke not my
problem with diet that's a Pepsi and I
realized how many ingredients have had
and so many of the ingredients I just
didn't really even understand and so I
thought I don't know maybe I'll just put
it to the side for now and just see what
happens but not really thinking that
would be any dramatic change and I
swapped out my diet my diet sodas for
plain water and at that point I really
realized that you know I had things were
getting better my energy levels were
coming back my skin was better and I was
losing weight and in two and a half
weeks and it was it was a pretty dismal
two and a half weeks like I felt like I
had a really bad case of the flu I just
didn't feel right and I now look back on
it as as detox like I didn't call that
Ben but I was really getting off of you
know at that time it was Splenda and
NutraSweet and some of the other
sweeteners that were going into these
diet diet drinks that I was drinking and
I had lost 24 pounds in two and a half
weeks my skin had cleared up my energy
levels were back and that's when I was
like God I've actually been marketed to
and I've been told that something is
better for me because it has the word
diet and that for me was like this
epiphany and again like I had I'd grown
up in the publishing industry and the in
the tech industry I never really paid
attention to you know labels on food as
being tricky and so at that point you
know I was kind of living my life and
let you know another six months pass and
you know I kept losing weight I sort of
went through a period wondering if I was
actually really sick because I was
losing weight so much faster and you
know my skin continued to stay great and
you know my energy levels great and and
by the time six months rolled around by
a I had lost 55 pounds which was kind of
my you know college weight it was like
my goal weight and it was dramatic like
you know people would see me and they
were like gosh you know wow you look
like you lost a lotta weight and I'm
like yeah I did and everyone's like you
okay and I'm like yeah no I'm really
good I feel I feel really good and
you're like well what diet were you on I
was like I wasn't really on a diet I
actually stopped drinking diet soda and
that's when I realized that I
educating so many people about my
experience including the guy who was
stuck in shelves at Whole Foods when I
decided I really want
I started in order to drink water
because then I realized I really wasn't
a water drinker after all I thought I
don't know how long I can do this
because I just I'm so bored by to ignore
it
so it's slicing up fruit and throwing it
in water and and then I went looking at
my favorite Whole Foods in San Francisco
for that product and everything had
sweeteners in it that had fruit and then
a lot of times the fruit wasn't even you
know real fruit that they were using it
was you know lots of other stuff so I
you know really saw this like need in
the market but I never really thought oh
I should I should like go become a
beverage entrepreneur I mean I really
saw it as like you know this is this is
criminal what I've experienced and so
many people really do want health but I
have a really hard time finding us and
so you have this epiphany and you say
okay you know what like water is boring
it's hard to drink it just you know
plain tap water or bottled water week
after week and adding fruit sort of you
know changes that dramatically right
it's good for you and it's still water
but it's got a flavor it's got flavor
and it like lets you drink it
consistently so you start this business
how do you make it the first year like
do you go to third-party manufacturers
and say hey I'm interested in making
hint water or are you making it at home
I'm always curious like are you cutting
up fruit as a third party manufacturer
doing that how like how do you guys make
this stuff yeah so we so initially I
mean I was making it at home and and
literally cutting up fruit and throwing
it in water and then what I realized
pretty quickly I don't know if anyone's
ever sliced a fruit and thrown it into a
pitcher but if you you know so even if
you put that in the refrigerator what
you need to do you know from a bacterial
standpoint you can't leave it off but on
the counter for too long but it's sort
of I used to say it would get likes
Meggy looking like it would have you
know the water or the
fruit would actually get sort of soft it
would just like the Pope would be sort
of funky after a while and it just
wouldn't taste as good so I started to
try and figure out like why was that and
then what I realized is that if we
actually took you know the skins and
oils of the fruit and created it our own
extracts and and then dropped a few of
those into the water then we could
actually you know still be using fruit
but you know we're oftentimes we're
using the rind so people like we just
recently came out with a lime there are
a lemon flavor and people were asking us
for years like you know why don't you
have a lemon flavor it's really odd and
because a lot of times we're actually
using the skins and most of the time
we're using the skins and oils and so it
would almost taste like you know that
the lemon naturally has like a you know
it can taste almost like a turpentine
almost like a furniture polish like sort
of smell to it now totally and so you
know it's just again it was trying to
figure out exactly how we could do that
in the right way that it wasn't you know
like reminding people of of that I mean
same with cherry I mean cherry so so
often reminds people love bad cherry
medicine cost medicine that they used to
take as a kid and you know that was the
same thing it was like you know we just
wanted to make sure and again we're not
using sugars or diet or any type of you
know stevia or diet sweeteners in it too
so it's it's really there's not a whole
lot to hide behind it's really a matter
of the type of lemon the type of cherry
the process and and you know so often
times you know people will say to us
well you know how do you get that
well-rounded taste like year-round and
and oftentimes we're using actually
grape skins to actually round it out but
again it's all you know vegan and I say
that but a lot of people say like oh
it's fruit of course it's vegan and I'm
like well actually that's not the case I
mean that was my epiphany when I was
looking at a lot of these you know
so-called diet diet drinks that were out
there a lot of them that are claiming to
be
you know fruit are actually using things
like bone marrow natural the turn girl
in general has a pretty wide definition
and so so you know cockroach wings for
example are considered you know magical
they're they're oftentimes used for food
coloring the red color in particular so
you know I always tell people that you
know even bone marrow like even if you
are okay with you know eating bone
marrow at a French restaurant a lot of
people think that you know the fact that
they're actually drinking bone marrow
and some of their drinks is kind of you
know gross and and the fact that we're
not actually they calling that out in
all true drinks it's just that is creamy
right yeah
yeah I'm okay I'd be okay eating
chocolate-covered cockroach wings once
in my life but I'd want to know what I
was eating if there were cockroach wings
in you know a blow pop because it was
bread I'd want to know that before I put
it in my mouth like that type of
transparency it seems like it should be
table stakes these days in the food and
beverage industry like an awesome bone
marrow I mean you know either
you know that's one where you know more
and more we're seeing people you know
not that they're vegetarians right or
vegan and and just like they they are
there's you know some mainstream drinks
that are out there that they've thought
they've been drinking for years that
actually have that so so that was you
know for me that that was you know
really kind of we I probably spent you
know close to a year actually trying to
figure out we looked at a lot of flavor
houses because I had you know run into I
was trying to find a co-packer to
actually bottle it we kept getting
pointed to all these flavor houses and
and that's the challenge that we
couldn't actually I mean this was 15
years ago we couldn't really figure out
what was in all of these flavors and a
lot of the flavors just were not as real
as you know we wanted them to be so that
was when we started creating our huh and
can you talk to me a little bit about
that
about what it looks like today at your
co-packer today or but your bottling
facility are they do they have like the
rinds of lemons and you know pineapples
and grapes and skins and oils does that
happen a third party facility how does
that work cuz like if there that must be
a you know I'm always amazed at
businesses like yours only because the
because the drink is so spectacular but
just like making it do you have like you
know I'm reading this book by about
McDonald's and they're talking about how
they perfected the French fry and for a
while they were like okay we got to make
sure we get the oil right and the time
right and then it turns out that like
that's not the only thing that matters
because if you throw cold potatoes in
ten oil it's very different than if you
throw warm potatoes and then it matters
in terms of like the sugar and starch
that's already in a potato so they have
to go they ultimately had to go back all
the way to the manufacturer of like the
potato in Idaho in order to make a
consistent french fry for product like
yours you're talking about rinds and
oils of like lemons and grapefruits and
grapes is your co-packer doing that are
they like getting these rinds and sort
of mixing it with water what does that
operational complexity look like no we
actually have so we now have a we have a
third party that just works for us that
puts that creates tap for us so they do
have that but what but we have multiple
co-packers we are only distributing in
the u.s. today but we send that into our
co-packers so yes there any like crazy
stats there are you can you say like you
know we you know like I looked at
something about like about Panda Express
and they're like we use 30,000 pounds of
chicken every X number of days or
something to that effect do you got luck
are you like oh my god
where the Lord we're one of the largest
consumers of grapefruit skins in the
country yeah you know I I don't think we
I mean we use such a tiny amount I mean
in every bottle there's only like two to
three drops of the oil and so I wouldn't
actually say that you know we were like
a major producer of it I mean what's
really interesting about it we you know
people always ask us like you know do
you use organic fruit and we try to use
organic whenever we can but you know the
key thing for us
is no pesticides and what I always tell
people about organic fruit when you go
in to you know these co-packers and you
know our original co-packing plant that
we used was and still use it every once
in a while is that they also do they're
on an apple orchard so they have you
know lots of apples and they do other
people's products or and in and I'm just
amazed at how much fruit that actually
gets produced if into juices that
actually has mold on it and so you know
I I mean it's it's a problem and so you
know we don't want that's sort of
another reason why we really want to
produce our own our own flavors too
because we're you know we have a lot
more control over that and being able to
see that you know we're we're getting
what we're getting you know that doesn't
have that doesn't have the mold on it
but just in terms of you know complexity
I mean we make it you know easy to to
you know drink our water and and you
know it's pretty it's it looks pretty
simple on the outside the truth is is
it's not that simple because of tempo
and you know and and everything else
about it but I always you know you and I
have talked as as founders I mean you
know there's all these founders stories
that I actually my book is coming out in
October that really dives into a lot of
these you know nightmare stories along
the way you know of creating not just
hint but just sort of like other stuff
for me oh well and and sort of my I was
in the early days of CNN I mean just
sort of a you know lifeline a little bit
but and what I've learned along the way
but but you know it's interesting we we
produced the first non-alcoholic water
company that didn't have with fruit in
it that didn't have preservatives in it
and so and for me I really you know just
didn't trust the word preservative when
I first started I couldn't exactly look
back
right and it's just and I thought I kept
asking the question I go to these
co-packers and I kept asking the
question like you know why do we need
preservatives and they're like because
in order to have a shelf life to go
beyond the shelf at Target you need to
have you know extend the shelf life
otherwise you know you're you're not
going to be able to grow this company
and so you know there was a point
probably a year into being you know in
Whole Foods we weren't probably a little
over half the country and we almost just
shut the company down because we just
couldn't figure out how to do it and you
know my husband Theo who's our chief
operating officer I mean I really give
him full credit I mean we literally like
thought we had tried aseptic packaging
and and you know really just we're
looking at all different ways to
ultimately do this and then finally I
remember him getting up in the middle of
the night and I heard him out in the
kitchen really trying to figure this out
and I said what are you doing and he was
like you know I'm just trying to figure
out if we can use heat and just to
actually you know but it's tricky
because of the sugars and you know you
don't want you know to turn the fruit
and I always tell people you know just
in layman's terms it's like a cooked
carrot versus a raw carrot or a you know
rock Roth strawberry versus a Robert
very different type of thing and so you
have to be very careful with it and so
it's not a straight shot of heat if
there's actually you know ups and downs
along the way in order to make sure that
that doesn't you know change and so when
I talk about like this is a product that
is not easy I mean it's probably you
know the biggest reason why companies
like have had a hard time replicating it
over the years because it's it's you
know it takes time and it's you know
it's an artisan product that is that is
really you know priced as a mainstream
product for you know anyone to enjoy and
so and so the heat is that like a form
of pasteurization that you're doing in
order to provide shelf shelf life gotcha
okay and so that was like one of early
on you're basically like we cannot put
this
the shelf anywhere because the shelf
life is several weeks as opposed to you
know a year or two in which is what you
really need to get intellect or yeah and
so we assume I mean this is this is a
segment my book I mean it's you know
it's it's like funny now it wasn't funny
then but I mean we used to go into Whole
Foods and we'd stock the shelves in
Whole Foods and we actually had
inventory in our warehouse and in our
garage but we would just tell them like
oh we we this is all we have we're out
of stock and so they would yell at us
because they're like you guys don't have
enough stock you know to maintain this
relationship and the truth was was that
we were really nervous that we didn't
have you know the stability on the
project and you know I always tell
entrepreneurs this too we were you know
CEO who's you know my husband and our
chief operating officer I mean he was an
attorney prior to helping me start hint
and he had worked on the the case I
don't know if you remember voilá
when they had the e.coli you know a few
kids died I mean it was horrible and
they were not like pasteurizing the
product and it was awful and so he
learned like a lot about you know shelf
stability but also you know the dangers
of it and so every single day literally
in the early days of hand I mean we were
taking our product to a lab to make sure
that you know it was actually I mean it
was truly we believed it was safe you
know and knew that you know we didn't
want to mess around with people's lives
at all but when I see that you know I've
talked I'm sure you've talked to many
entrepreneurs and and especially in the
food space I mean it's just it's
frightening to me sometimes when I hear
like people are like oh yeah no we
haven't we haven't really figured it out
because our volumes aren't that big and
I'm yeah an ingestible that's nuts
yes how could you possibly think of
that's okay there was activity over
there's a start-up Deora brand that
launched a couple years ago identity
argot had stability issues all of their
deal wrote would melt basically three
months into their shelf life and you
know they got
called a target target ended up giving
native their shelf space and it was a
complete disaster and like from that
perspective it's bad both from a brand
perspective from a customer perspective
his target doesn't really trust your
brand any longer and from a you know
consumer perspective because you're
selling an inferior product or an
ingestible product that could harm a
consumer that's like unforgivable yeah I
do yeah it's crazy I do want to talk a
little bit more about that you know in
preparation for this podcast I looked at
you know I did a bunch of research on
him today you guys are a massive company
you know like uh uh you know there was
this guy that works at native who would
not drink any water he would only drink
hint water I'm pretty sure he brushes
his teeth whatever
and anytime we'd have to travel he would
have to instacart Hinch water to the
hotel before we landed so we've gotta
look Vegas and New Orleans and you know
different like in Minneapolis and he was
instacart in water it was crazy a huge
fan of him
and you know from from what I can tell
look you know I've seen articles in 2006
2018 you guys were somewhere in the 90
to 100 million dollar run right back you
know back then what were the numbers
looking like in 2005 and where were you
getting sales from because you know this
is 15 years ago direct consumer isn't
nearly what it is today where were those
sales from and what is it would those
sales look like so it's uh so you know
we started out I mean literally
delivering cases and and you know I was
doing and initially I just had my fourth
child and and you know I joke about this
but I think the you know just really
thought I was out of my mind I mean I
had four kids it just sticks and I'm you
know a previous vice president you know
at Ebony and you know it's he's like
wait I get that it got you really
healthy but why do you really want to do
this I mean you're you know you could go
get a job somewhere else and you know go
make a lot of money and and I thought
you know for me it was really about you
know resetting health for people and and
like I didn't care whether or not I
didn't set off in my business plan to
actually
Oh build a billion-dollar company or
become the next red bull or vitamin
water or whatever for me it was really
about you know helping people change
health and I really believe when I
described this company to people I said
if I can actually just get it in the
hands of people especially the people
that are drinking these you know
flavored waters or vitamin waters or
diet sodas or even you know full-fledged
sugar sodas and get them to drink our
product
maybe they'll eventually get to water
maybe they'll never get to plain water
ever but like we could actually change
health and you know the world and you
know in our little you know area or
whatever and you know that that did not
only mean you know helping people too
like we were here and early on that this
was you know and I saw it myself helping
me lose weight but it was also you know
type-2 diabetes at that time was
probably 2% of the population I mean
it's you know upwards of forty five
percent of the population just in the
u.s. have you know of type 2 diabetes or
prediabetes and heart disease and lots
of other things so I thought you know
that how do I get it in the hands of
people and so when we initially went
into Whole Foods I mean that was the
first retailer and around the Bay Area
went into some others I was actually
interviewing sort of like not seriously
interviewing but had had a few
conversations with this guy of meat
cortisone II who was at Google at the
time and he worked with my husband at
Netscape and and so Amin was talking to
me about a job at Google and you know
he's really nice and kept upping the
salary that he was talking to me about
and after a while I was just like you
know what I mean like you know it's
really nice and you're I consider you a
friend in this job you know likes you a
lot but for me it's really about it's
not about an offer right now it's about
I don't really want to commute down to
you know Palo Alto and Mountain View I
really want to stay up in the Bay Area
but then I really you know I just want
to go and do this
and see if I can actually help lots of
people and so that was a major turning
point for him because amede you know
somewhat joking but he was like oh well
do you have do you have a sample of this
product and I pulled it out of my bag
and he was like of course you have a
sample of the product and you actually
selling him during a job interview in
order to get hint water into Mountain
View's offices yeah but I never even
thought of it as yeah sure but he said
to me he was like oh you know we have
the sky Charlie you was our chef and you
know he will talk to Charlie about it
and and see and I was like okay cool
yeah if you guys like want it in your
offices I'd be really fun and I had no
idea what I had stumbled upon and you
know Charlie ends up calling saying hey
I really like a meet a lot like can you
send me some samples of the drain yeah
we'll give it a try and see what happens
we've been doing food and it's fun well
but let's you know give him to try as
well and and you know he called back a
couple days later and he's like do you
guys have more supply and I'm like yeah
how do you have you know another office
or he said oh we're just going through
this like crazy to vary within like two
weeks of that conversation we don't need
Google became our number one retailer I
mean I saw your number two accounts you
know Whole Foods and Google's sort of
like looking into every gotcha
yeah they quickly overtook it I mean
like I say retailer and quote right they
weren't really a real killer yeah and
they were they were just in you know
it's interesting because Google was
really trying to make sure that they had
healthcare better for you you know
products not just drinks but also food
like they were I mean they were really
aware of it and very early and so and
what you're yes so that was like the
beginning of 2006 and so I mean that was
like and again like we were you know
still trying to get our shelf life or
shelf life was maybe six months and we
were trying to figure out if we could
you know get it higher at me today our
shelf life is two years do those b2b
sales still make up a
again part of your revenue but you know
you selling to Google I know I
discovered your product and startup as
well when I was working out of somebody
else's office and was in the
refrigerator those pdb sales make up a
significant percentage of our revenue
today or is it sort of like now you're
in Whole Foods and Target and Walmart
and sell on Amazon and so it's still
nice but less significant
well it's interesting I mean we're we're
obviously taping this during a crazy
time in history sure yes that's right
and so our food service sales you know
just because nobody's going into offices
is actually cut with it's interesting
we're actually talking to a lot of the
executives that some of these companies
and some of them are even sending them
home cases home to their employees just
as a you know gifting them just to say
hey continue to stay healthy but you
know food service has really been I mean
that the sort of corporate food service
has been massive for us started with the
tech companies in Silicon Valley that
just really embraced this and then they
would embraced us and then they would go
into their local store and say hey look
you for the product yeah yeah that's
great what a great look flywheel effect
ya know and I always tell entrepreneurs
too it's like you know it wasn't
strategic that we I said God if I can
just go get Google or I can go get
Facebook I mean I remember you know
Sheryl Sandberg's assistant when she
left Google and she went to Facebook and
she called me and said hey you know what
you guys delivered this company Facebook
and they were still in Palo Alto at the
time so I was like sure you know no
problem is crazy yeah and so that's it
and so what is it
and so when did you look you know in
2005 you get Whole Foods 2006 Google
comes along Facebook comes along the
Business Objects some point obviously
the you know something sets in your mind
we like I'm not just delivering products
anymore
this can be a legitimately large
business at what point did you raise
money like you know you uh compared to
most of the startups that I speak with
in San Francisco that have not been
around for 15 years you know it's pretty
recently like you know their their first
chat one
more than five or six years ago when did
you guys first raise money in the
lifecycle of your butt so I think it was
early 2007 and you know I we sort of did
this a little bit differently I mean
maybe to some extent you know I I think
you know you're probably you very
similar where you know we really thought
early on that I still wanted to have
like dinner with my friends and not have
them in us in me like how you know how's
it going right so I I was able I mean we
we had made a little bit of money and
you know with Netscape and with AOL and
so and we thought you know we have to be
careful but let's just let's just try
and see how long we can go with
self-funding and you know I always tell
entrepreneurs to I mean we have an
amazing house in San Francisco that we
had gutted and remodeled and all you
know four kids were you know that we had
a baby at the time but the three kids
were in private preschools and private
schools in San Francisco and you know I
remember looking at Theo one night
saying like you know this is not really
that sustainable if we're gonna be
sitting here like trying to pay for
school like how can we actually conserve
money and actually put it into you know
our company and so yeah that's when we
decided let's go find good public
schools around the Bay Area and and you
know and that's what we did and we move
dr. Marin cut Marin County and you know
again like marinas gorgeous and nice it
wasn't where we were sacrificing so much
yeah and so today can you talk about so
today can you talk a little bit about
how much you've raised you know over the
last 15 years yeah I mean we've raised
you know this this part is all public I
think it's a little over 60 million but
we've raised in a sort of a different
way we we haven't done venture or you
know no private equity we have a family
office out of Brussels which was you
know they've got a little more money
into the company there into their their
family office then than they originally
did but it really
stemmed off of the Stella veer family
and said what you put why did you like
the family office first as a VC look
it's apparent to me to be clear I just
want to make sure listeners understand
like why is a family office different or
better for you than a VC yeah I mean I
sorted I didn't know back then when when
we necessarily took money but these guys
had actually been investors and
vitaminwater and vitaminwater
know had sold to coca-cola and so part
of their they came to us and sort of
part of their you know thinking was we
really want to invest in you know
healthy lifestyle and better for you
products outside of Europe and so they
were looking you know at the hint and
you know approached us and said like why
wouldn't you take money you know we add
advisory we had an advisory role with
vitaminwater and we were big investors
and so you know that was really like our
thinking back then but you know I laugh
and I don't know if you ever talked to
sort of Silicon Valley investors I mean
look we are stopped in most of the
Silicon Valley you know offices and and
but and you know we definitely when we
were going out and raising money I mean
we would pitch some of these people and
what's interesting is that so many of
these people you know they love drinking
here it would always start off like oh
we drinking all the time we love your
product everything's great but many of
those people you know people always
invest in what they know and and what
they think they can add value to and so
I think that they viewed us as a company
that if we actually were doing it right
then you know coca-cola would come in
and they would just knock us off and the
truth is I mean this sort of you know
I'm skipping to the end game on this but
the truth is is like you know Coca
Cola's knocked us off like six times
I mean and every time it's just not with
their core competencies you know you
know when people ask me to say yeah
people will ask me the same question why
do I attend P&G build their own version
native and I'm like it's the same reason
that when you look at a bird you don't
you're not like oh now I know how to fly
just because you've seen something grow
who doesn't mean that it's in your DNA
and the people who work at coca-cola
didn't start coca-cola there are
stewards of multi-billion dollar brands
like sprite and you know Diet Coke and
and Powerade and so like their skill set
is to steward those brands and grow them
as fast as possible but in a very
different way than going from but the
difference between going from zero to 50
million is very different than going
from 1 billion to 1 billion and 500
million dollars right or even 1 million
1 million 50 million dollars like it's a
very different skill set I mean sorry
when the first you know when the first
time that they came in and and knocked
us off I mean I was talking about it was
on a timeline but like that was a really
bad day I'm sure you guys have this you
know same day by one of these big guys
I'm good what I realized is that it
actually has helped us to get more space
because they eventually have given up
because you know there's probably
internal fights especially you know when
you look at kind of the mothership of
these soda companies it's sugar right
which is sort which is totally counter
to what we're doing we're just getting
people to drink water that tastes better
and that's it and so it's in and so
every single time they've come out with
a drink that is a you know competitor
it's just it's just we've noticed it's
hard for them and we end up getting more
space yes just going back to your VC
question I mean we would talk to these
VCS and you know first of all a lot of
these species I mean the core consumer
for diet coke is female and it's no
surprise there's a lot of VCs that are
not female and especially you know 12 13
years ago when I was pitching so I be in
there talking about you know my diet
coke addiction and they would they would
look at me like well that wasn't really
addiction was it and I was like oh no it
was it was real and like it was right up
there with like you know cigarette
addiction or like I'm like the same
timeline and they're like
really like people actually have that
and you know it and again it was just
not what they knew and so they would
still keep ordering cases in cases a
hint to consume in fact some VCS have
told me that they won't invest in in
tech companies unless they have hints in
the office because they really really
believe that like they that they you
know understand what their employees
need to stay healthy I mean crazy
stories like that a lot of its most but
but yeah I mean they just wouldn't end
up investing and so and so we ended up
you know going a different route and and
you know just raising from a lot of
individuals so we have over 100
investors and the company and and so
John Legend is on your cap table I think
my brother actually transparency is also
on your cap table but I want to fast
forward a little bit to today you know
I've heard you talk a lot about how
about 40% of your business is online now
versus brick and mortar which is crazy
because I think it's like um you know I
won't talk to you a little bit about
shipping costs later on in this
conversation and how you sort of manage
those because you know shipping water is
not an easy thing to do but let's talk a
little like um you know 40 percent of it
is online sixty percent is in
brick-and-mortar stores can you talk a
little bit about the brick-and-mortar
stores that you're in right now yeah
it's I you know we've we've started in
sort of a specialty store market which
is like the you know Whole Foods and
sprouts and and some of the local ones
and then went into the conventional
grocery I think where we really had the
toughest challenge in congressional or
in conventional grocery was with you
know we just didn't have the bandwidth
and and the people that the big you know
soda companies have and so we would you
know just get knocked off the shelf and
you know we wouldn't have the slotting
fees and and you know lots of stuff was
going on I think that's where you know
we really started to realize not only
from a revenue standpoint but also from
a you know it just wasn't as as
challenging to compete inside of these
firms and then you know lots of other it
wasn't just Silicon Valley but lots of
offices in New York
we're cropping up that were extensions
of Silicon Valley or LA or whatever and
so we started getting into more and more
and then you know companies that wanted
to be like Facebook and Google and you
know recruit people like they would they
would end up putting us in so you know
we became you know pretty giant in those
companies and then and then you know we
we finally got into target a few years
ago you know in a in a pretty pretty
decent sized way we were you know we
started out with a few feet of space I
mean it again like I'm sure you and I
could swap stories on this it's just you
know we we had gotten to a point where
we sort of understood like if we didn't
have enough shelf space then you know we
just wouldn't yeah yeah and so we would
like look little and so I remember
reading a case study on Tom's you know
the Tom's I mean their toothpaste and
Pennsylvania yeah lots of tots of Maine
and lots of things this was you know
before they were acquired but I remember
hearing sort of their sales plans and
they talked to Beth about like they got
to a point where they would tell buyers
like you know if you don't give us this
kind of space you know they their sales
team would just say I you're just not
ready for us short like welcome back
like it's all good
and so we've really started saying that
you know to these large retailers
because we knew that we would fail it
unless we actually had a certain
presence and so we we ended up going
into target and then you know really got
smarter about the data too and and
started realizing I mean it's I'll give
you a crazy statistic I mean in in
target we do more dollars per square
foot than some of the large brands like
a vitamin water for example and and so
that is like when you can actually take
that kind of data and you can't do that
when you're first starting a company
right and you're not even gonna register
on this data but when you start being
able to articulate that to these buyers
I mean you you know you're just getting
smarter about you know the data and sort
of what you're doing and I think just
sort of how that relates for us into the
e-commerce side of the business - I mean
that you know is sort of its own story I
mean we started we we had gotten into
Starbucks another big food service
company we were in 11,000 Starbucks and
you know which was a great day when we
rolled out in Starbucks and we were only
one flavor it was the blackberry and but
we were you know rolling along and doing
you know two to three times what their
goals were for us and and one day we got
a call from a buyer at Starbucks that
said hey we're you know we're gonna
bounce you out of here because because
Howard Schultz said that you know we're
only going to have beverage brands in
here that are distributed by Pepsi
because Pepsi is actually doing the
distribution for us for our ready to
drink Starbucks drink and and so I
always you know my big lesson learned
from that day was you know don't have
too many eggs in one basket I mean
really that was a bad day and you know I
don't cry often but I went home and I
cried and I thought how am I gonna tell
my investors aboard about this and then
I remember a couple weeks later you know
I resurfaced and I'm like look I'm not
gonna lie it was really bad that we got
bounced out of there but at the end of
the day we just need to find these
consumers because we were doing well and
Starbucks actually paid us for product
and they exposed us to places like
Chicago and you know lots of places
taxes and and places where we didn't
even have distribution and so a couple
of weeks after that happened we got
another email from from you know another
big brand they weren't even that big
back well they were pretty big but they
didn't have a grocery business I guess
it was six seven years ago at Amazon and
they were
grocery business and I you know took the
email and I said you know tell me about
this grocery business and I I mean I had
dealt with Jeff Bezos in the early days
when he was just a book
you know retailer when I was running
when I was running aol's business and I
really believed that I wasn't I didn't
know if I really believed I I wasn't
sure whether or not this was a serious
business because I thought Amazon gets
into little businesses and sometimes you
hear about them and sometimes you don't
and yeah I wasn't sure whether or not
they could be serious and in the grocery
business because of weight and all kinds
of issues I thought I don't know maybe
they have it figured out because they're
doing books and those are pretty heavy
and so but I had a lot of you know
blackberry hint in the warehouse that
was supposed to be you know going to
Starbucks and so I sold it to Amazon
instead I sold it to Amazon and so that
was the only flavor that we had on
Amazon and then very quickly they you
know told us like you guys are one of
the number one products in grocery but
in addition to that what we're seeing is
that you know this goes back to the data
side of the story they they said we're
seeing that your consumer is also buying
things like you know
and you know better for you product and
I thought wow that's really interesting
and I asked Amazon for the emails of
these consumers because I was like I'd
really like to reach out to them
and they said no way you're not getting
love to ask you but yeah sorry go ahead
now well I'd love to ask you a little
bit more about the brick but about the
data side of things which you were
talking about look like you know at
native we were entirely
direct-to-consumer through our own
website so we understood things like aov
really well repeat purchase rate when
customers would purchase and if they
didn't in you know X number of days what
we should be doing in order to retain
them and once we launched into Target
and Walmart and CVS and Walgreens like
that data became a lot more grey to us
we did you know it was hard to
understand we'd be purchased right
because did you buy it or did you buy on
our site and then you bought at Target
did you buy and Target and then you
bought on our website we don't know if
it's your first purchase or your second
did you guys experience the same type of
like fuzziness with your data once you
launched like you know going from
selling everything yourself in 2005 to
now having a robust online store of
robust Amazon score a big target
business
do you guys experience that data
fuzziness or like is there something
that you're doing to sort of help you
through that morass so I so you know we
obviously have sales numbers that that
can go and buy store and and I say
obvious like you you know again you get
to a certain level in these stores and
and they'll start to give you some of
this yeah it is does somebody like a
target we definitely have that and then
we can you know match that with how
we're doing on our own website and which
is what we did after you know Amazon but
it's uh you know it's it's still very
difficult for us to see that you know
Lisa Smith is purchasing on you know
drinking calm and then yeah they're also
going at Target yeah I think the Holy
Grail that's the holy grail of
attribution yeah and I think it's it's
really tough I mean the only way you
know I think electronics
able to do it because they get you to
like get a you know products like like
our first but I think what online has
allowed us to do is when we see for
example we can go back into you know
I'll pick on Target or Costco we're
going in nationwide in to enter Costco
and the next few weeks so it's you know
it's interesting because we're able to
say to them like you know here's our top
ten markets or cities inside of you know
are drinking calm and we can also match
that to a target we don't necessarily
have to say oh this is target's data but
we can say oh this is a major retailer
and we can show this and you know again
you get in front of a buyer that really
understands the data and it's just it's
obvious that they're missing sure right
and then also I think from a standpoint
of the one other thing that I'll just
say really quickly that it allows us to
do is that you know I always say to
entrepreneurs that if for example a
major retailer that's in Florida was to
just come and turn you off as a consumer
you know it's just I we're gonna kick
you out of here and you don't know a lot
gonna be in here you know what I
realized is that without having our own
online site we're actually able to go in
and market so you're you're really
hedging your bets
sure and and it allows you you know to
be able to grow the business I mean what
I've realized now was that retailers
need to do what they need to do right
and and I need to do what I need to do
for hands as well and so the more you
can have you know options out there and
certainly during you know this whole
corona incident I mean it's you know
we're considered essential so they're
still in stores and and you know going
in I'm doing my part to help the sales
team once a day to go in and check on
supply and and etc but you know I think
being able to you know have a
direct-to-consumer business that is you
know higher now than forty percent of
our overall
business has allowed us you know to
really like grow our business when you
know these restocking issues are you
know sure someone else's problem and
unfortunately products get hit by it
yeah and then do you like you know you
were talking about getting into Costco
in the next few weeks which is amazing
congratulations first when it comes to
that do you find other pricing issues
among the retailers that you have in
Amazon look for a native it was hard to
hold the price it's hard to hold the
price everywhere consistently like you
know today Walmart will sell well 1197
and target will sell at $11.99 but
that's basically the same price you know
one of our concerns was that we would
all of a sudden have somebody drop the
price to nine dollars or eight dollars
and then have to deal with something
like that do you guys have any of those
issues or are you guys sort of like good
when it comes to pricing on the product
so we never try to you know we give us
suggested retail price and people have
different margins that they're working
on but but you know look Walmart and
Target have amazing algorithms that will
change on a dime you know depending and
you know and and so you know we have
consumers who write to us and ask us we
buy on your side or should we go to
Target buy the product you know they
they're like we just want to know where
what's best for the small business yeah
right and so we always say to people
like wherever you want your the consumer
you're in charge
any place that we deal with is you know
like we're excited that they're you're
growing your black boots there's always
going to be people that are going to
come to native site or hint site and you
know buy and I think there's this
perception that it's like fresher if you
you know get the product on our site and
you know that's not true I mean as soon
as we make our product and you know I
mean we actually it's a longer
conversation but that's sort of another
thing and we really don't we we pretty
much are making our product on to me and
I mean as as soon as like we we spend
very little money in warehousing because
we're we're making it and it is going
out the door and
so and it's you know constantly running
but we've got sort of the supply chain
thing where you know I think pretty
advanced about that so even it through
this whole corona you know situation
you know I saw early on probably a week
before people were even talking about
sort of these hoarding issue news and
out of stock issues I said to our sales
team like this whole auto-replenishment
thing is not working that may not many
many stores that I've been into and you
know the response I got back from our
team was like well they keep telling us
that they're on auto-replenishment and
you know I mean we also have a product
where we're you know depending on how
much space we have in stores if people
come in and buy 10 bottles of hint which
is common you know they'll they'll wipe
out the shell right yeah that's close
and so it should and so it's supposed to
match with register data to say like oh
you've got to automatically reorder it
but the stores have never seen anything
like this not just for hint but for like
other products and so you know they just
couldn't keep up with it so we went
around to all of the buyers of all of
our kind of all of our companies that we
work with and we said look there's
there's definitely an auto replenishment
product and and somewhere in here but
you know we're not going to try and
figure this out and we don't expect you
to go figure this out if you wanna you
know like order from us directly we've
got trucks that will truck our product
right into you and you know I'd say over
50% of the people that we deal with just
said you know yeah let's do that
even if it's just for a couple of
truckloads to catch us up that's fine
but again like you know the number of
shelves that I look at now and that are
just empty you know I think I think we
we just watch it really carefully and
you know people are like how did you
know that and I said I just I don't know
I've been you know I I've watched it and
you know it's it's what great founders
and CEOs or to do you need to really
understand like why is this happening
and I'm sure once you know the whole
everybody gets back to work
goes back into an office and you know no
I'm sure the number one thing that a lot
of these grocery retailers are gonna do
is figure out this auto-replenishment
thing because it's a mess
it's you know it's personally and I
don't know who owns those companies and
those software's but they're they're not
they're not perfect sure would love to
shift the conversation really quickly to
marketing have a couple questions here
one have you guys had a booth at Expo
West in the past and I'm pretty certain
you have or you've been taxed by West
find those types of events do you find
out types of events helpful to your
business to like network with buyers
like I'm sure there are a lot of people
who are listening who are gonna be
starting food service businesses or who
in the or in the food or beverage
industry who you know may not want to
spend the money it takes to get in tax
by West did you find that to be helpful
for when you were growing hint yep for
sure I mean our first one our first show
was at fancy food in New York yeah and
in a few weeks after we actually put the
first bottle on the shelf at Whole Foods
and I mean I literally got the worst
space possible and in New York Birkin
and I had no idea you know a bit just
some tech booths but I just thought I
mean it happened so last-minute I
literally like brought my own table in
and set it up and it was just I mean it
was super bare-bones and we had every
buyer from Whole Foods lining up so I
always tell you know entrepreneurs to it
it's like sometimes when you actually
look pretty scrappy but you have a great
product it like it's it's you know
they're they're gonna come come by you
and you know and and they'll they'll
recognize that you're you know that
you're authentic and real and you know I
I mean I I laugh now because I had no
idea what uNFI was and some of these
distributors have seen Cisco trucks
around but I had never really figured
figured that whole world out so that was
our first and then and I would say a
couple years later Expo West which is an
Anaheim every year that that's been I
mean that's a great show and I think the
one on the East Coast has has been an OK
show as well but the
a big one and yeah we've been doing it
for 14 years and I'd like some brands I
mean some brands like actually write
orders they are at the shows that's
never really been our purpose at our
goal I mean we use these trade shows not
only to you know get with buyers but
also to really understand what else is
going on in the marketplace from a
marketing standpoint and just talk to
other you know people there and and now
it's gotten to a point where you know
it's just a time I you know we have over
200 people in the company now and and so
for us we actually try and you know
staff our booth with people that you
know don't get to work the tradeshow
booths like we don't hire you know the
booth babes or whatever colors come and
yeah right we get we get our team in
there you know who just like love being
there or passionate about the product
yeah yeah you know I've always heard
things like when you're sampling it
costs go for instance you can either get
the Costco employee we used to hand out
samples in which case you'll barely move
any product but if you put your own team
member there who's really excited about
a product like hint water they will go
through samples really quickly and go
through sales much faster because they
have somebody who's authentic and
believes in the brand and passionate as
opposed to someone who's like you know
one of those people who is just handing
out tiny samples like go on go on your
way they actually know the brand and
when a consumer asked about it they can
respond to it but ton of questions I've
also noticed that you like this year you
guys had a Super Bowl commercial yeah it
was can you talk a little bit about that
like you know yeah that is insane I
would love to like understand how that
sort of came about you know I've seen
certainly seen the commercial where you
know somebody's talking about how they
really enjoy blackberry and they've got
blackberry on their face and somebody
else licks it off their face and they're
like the hint water they hit water
flavor
the blackberry flavoured hint water
tastes more like blackberries than real
blackberry can tell me about how that
came about can you tell me a little bit
about costs and stuff as well I think
everybody's always curious about Super
Bowl commercials
yeah and how like whether they're
extravagant or not we'd love to hear the
background yes so I mean it was a pretty
crazy story we had started to do some TV
and just run in remnants you know ads so
we shot three commercial
was actually in the fall and two of them
we had running and you know it's uh we
were running just for about eight weeks
on you know just various but like some
news channels so some people had seen it
and then some sort of overnight stuff we
were just sort of testing it and and
then we were also not only testing the
brand commercial but we were also
there's a tweet diversion and that is
direct-to-consumer so you could actually
you know you get an offer and and doing
all of that and so so we have this one
ad that was sitting in there and I don't
know it was it's a crazy story one
Sunday so I you know was that CNN for a
couple of years way way way back and I
had just run into a woman that worked
with me at CNN and it's now you know
pretty high-level at NBC and just
happened to see her at a conference and
earnings Laura and I was chatting with
her and I don't know one Sunday I just
was like I should just text her and just
ask her you know I knew it was on Fox
and I should just ask her who's like if
she knows anybody at Fox and if there's
any inventory and I had sort of heard
that they were sold out but I never
really trust what I hear and so she's
like oh yeah you should like you should
you know just Texas this guy he like
runs Fox Sports and he's a good friend
of mine and just tell him to Laura sent
you and he laughed he said oh no we're
totally sold out but he said you know
it's funny that you mentioned this that
there's I just spoke to somebody who was
doing regional stuff
and I was like what do you what do you
mean I mean obviously I know what a
region is but he said so in the major
areas like San Francisco in New York and
Chicago there's they have to leave a
little bit of inventory in those markets
and I said so you're saying that there's
like multiple people and and this is
literally two and a half weeks before
Super Bowl was running Wow and so I and
so he said do you have an ad and ice you
know it's sort of like I wasn't sure
that was it sure gonna be the advent I
was like
yeah we have an ad you boys do you Bluff
do you know there's uh he said yeah you
should talk to this guy you can drive
this one guy and he can get him for all
the markets I still didn't really think
that it was gonna happen but I was just
I don't know I was bored and amused by
it and I had never really you know I had
started joke like we've got it when we
were making these commercials I said
they have to be like something we could
run on the Superbowl one day but it was
kind of something that I just was
energizing the team about more than
actually thank you seriously about it
and so the guy reached out to me and I
was like okay so the Super Bowl is in
less than two weeks and you have
inventory in all of these markets and he
said you got in every market I have
inventory left and and so I I was like
you know so what do we have to do and he
said well your ad has to be like traffic
through not only the NFL or and not only
Fox but also the NFL and so you know a
couple days here a couple days there and
so you know the response back from my
team was like this that there is no way
like you I mean you're just dreaming
this is gonna be like five million like
I'm like we already have that it's like
it'll be fine you know the founder just
saying it's gonna be great you know it
was still I was getting shot down by
everybody in the company they were like
there's just no way but this is
happening and and so then 10 days before
I guess 11 days before the Super Bowl
I you know resurfaced it and I said you
know we should really we should really
go back and do this and I said to the I
said to my CMO I was like go back and
just say a guy like give him a lowball
offer and he's like err sold out for
national there's no way that they're
gonna go for it and I was like no what
is it was running out of time right so
one week before Friday before and I said
this whole thing has to be trafficked by
the NFL or else they're gonna be giving
the beast spots away to their own
advertisers by Tuesday morning it has to
so so at five o'clock Friday
turn in our bid on this and let's see
what happens and I mean I have to tell
you I mean we ended up getting getting
you know the overall plan was less than
50 percent I mean we got we we had
eighty percent of the country for less
than a million bucks and so eighty
percent of the country in terms of this
saw the ad for less than a million
dollars on a Super Bowl commercial
there's a 30-second spot on fifteen
thirty and so and so what was crazy is
that what they said to us is it will run
sometime during the Super Bowl it can be
anywhere I think it was like I can't
remember exactly I think it was anywhere
from 30 to 60 minutes before or I think
it was 30 to 45 minutes before the
halftime show or after we literally were
right before the halftime show so
everybody was coming in to see the
halftime no was shelling that's been
getting ready and saw the spot and it
was you know it it's a I'm you know it
was it did amazing and it and we were we
were so excited about it but not only
from a you know consumer perspective and
you know definitely it was you know
where you've got people licking each
other's faces which you know probably we
wouldn't run that out in today's climate
by yeah but he got people to remember it
and they were talking about it and it
was you know it like some a very small
percentage of the population was was you
know thought it was offensive that two
guys were licking each other's faces
like Gen X's and Gen Z's thought it was
hilarious 12 percentage of the
population will think everything is
offensive like if you run they'll think
it's offensive if you're gonna like if
you want to walk on eggshells and please
everybody you're not gonna do anything
yeah did you a bunch of friends texting
you being like hey I just saw your
you're like company on the super on a
Super Bowl that I have never said this
about my cell phone like my cell phone I
think I had over 400 texts within like
from all over the country just laying oh
my god oh
like and I think that that was the thing
- that what I was going to say is it
wasn't just consumers but it was also
you know people in the industry noticing
it was investors it was you know lots of
people most important was employees like
the excitement that they were getting
all these texts saying oh my gosh like
you know there's this er there's this
big soda
you know Pepsi is doing it and Coca
Cola's doing it and everybody's doing it
but then all the sister
the little underdog shows up yeah yeah
so that's an amazing story and and so
people people were so excited but again
I think it's just you know never lose
your scrappiness right like no matter
how big you get and and you know I think
my curiosity and also just my previous
life of sort of understanding like what
is trafficking and AD and it just like
stuff like that it just takes time right
and and we knew it was gonna clear but
we but we just like we were playing
against the clock and the guy that we
were dealing with like knew it like and
I just said like is your manager just
freaking out right now that you have
these open at this open as me it's like
kinda like can we get the advantage of
the leverage that you had that's
fantastic so so we've talked about like
some of your incredible marketing
successes it sounds like a Super Bowl ad
was fantastic you've had a bunch of
successes that like you know that trick
shows that you've gone to in terms of
getting in front of buyers can you talk
about any like tough marketing failures
that you've had you know at native we
had a bunch of marketing failures where
we tried to buy really large podcasts or
we try to you know buy our way into
places and it just failed spectacularly
where we'd spend tens of thousands of
dollars and it just didn't work out we
also had that when we tried like you
know I remember the first like couple
months that I launched the business
we've lost thousands of dollars trying
to buy Google Ads that's supposed to do
you know I'm sure there's gonna be a lot
of people who are listening to this
podcast who aren't nearly at the you
know level of scale that you're at but
want to realize that you're also a human
being and want to realize that you know
there's failures along the way
were there any like failures from a
marketing perspective that you had in
the last 15 years you can talk about
yeah I mean I would say a couple of
things to that first you know I again I
I was in advertising before so I sort of
always had this theory that unless we
you know could really get the frequency
that it wasn't worth it so you know we
didn't we never really it's like went
out and bought one billboard because I
just thought it like one billboard it's
just like anything right it's just
wasting money if we're if we're just
doing one thing and so I think that
we've always believed like you know buy
it buy a chunk in an area and you know
do do it right or just don't do it at
all and that sort of been our theory too
that you know just just not only from a
marketing district marketing brand
standpoint but also from a distribution
standpoint we've also just believed like
if we can't actually do well in a store
or in a market like we shouldn't be
there right and I think it's the same
sort of philosophy for like don't be
afraid to take your time and which is
sort of like you know not what everybody
would say like I mean we've had so many
you know brands that have said no you
got to get across the u.s. you got to
get into Kroger you gotta get Publix
like Costco fast fast fast and so many
of those companies aren't here anymore
because we just spent too fast right so
if you don't have the money to go into
those markets and really do it right I
mean my best advice would be you know
just do the markets they you can be
really good at well period right and and
like slow that growth but I would say
you know they're you know even I'm just
thinking about you know Facebook I mean
Facebook is sort of the the conversation
for Aldi to see you know brands right
and and figuring that out I think I
think it's just it's really uh you know
again don't put all your eggs in one
basket right and I think you have to
figure out constant
how do you continue to you know grow and
you know go back to your list and and
you know get the existing buyers to keep
buying until you find the right time to
ultimately you know get facebook to be
at a point where you know your cost of
customer acquisition isn't crazy so I
think that that's you know that's the
key thing a lot of people say to us like
why are you on Amazon but you're also
you know on your direct-to-consumer site
there's a value to us of being able to
have you know a name that we can go back
and market to and have a subscription
service and then you know all of those
things so it's surveys to understand
what a o V looks like and repeat
purchase rate looks like that's crazy
that people would ask you that there's
clearly value and you sort of having
your own direct channel with consumers
yeah totally and and I think it's just
it's again you know I never I mean I
look at even I think about I talk about
in my book the the whole Starbucks
situation I mean it was clearly
distribution I mean they were selling
millions of dollars to multi millions of
dollars of product every year but for us
it really was a marketing play where
they were getting us into all kinds of
you know there's a Starbucks on every
corner right and there every couple of
every couple of blocks and so we were
getting you know we were visible in so
many places and then you know when they
turned us off I really viewed that as a
failure for a lot of different reasons
including I blamed myself for not like
having you know too much in you know to
that relationship I mean they were
clearly buying we weren't writing them
large you know slotting fee chapters or
anything like that but I still had a lot
of inventory
I didn't there was a lot of risk with
that and you know what I've learned to
do though too is you know not be so hard
on yourself and create all this anxiety
around the fact that you know in some
ways he failed in some way she tried I
think instead figure out like you know
what was the good I'm a huge believer
that in fact when we
to Amazon at the guy who was the buyer
reached out and said oh I get your
product all the time at Starbucks and so
if if we were not in Starbucks won't be
an Amazon we wouldn't be an Amazon
you're a great story yeah right and so
every so sometimes it just takes a
minute to actually I'm sure you know the
the Google story for you and sort of
feeling like oh like I mean made a
mistake there or whatever if you sit
back for a minute and you actually just
say like what did I learn you know I got
that much smarter about how I do my buys
for this next one where I saved mine and
again like sometimes you have to connect
a bunch of different dots to actually
sometimes it takes time to figure that
stuff out but I I just don't really view
you know life in general as failing as
much as you know I'm gonna it's teaching
me that I can do better on the on the
next run and and maybe that also is you
know telling an audience that here's
what I learned along the way I mean you
know and and these are the lessons maybe
it's you know I'm giving back to other
people to learn from you know my mistake
my feel ya know whatever but but I I
just I'm a huge believer that that's
that's such an important piece of this
as well and you know you make the best
decision based on the best information
that you have and you know and I think
that that's that that is so key and and
sometimes you know that's challenging
too because I'm sure you know you you
have things in your head that you maybe
did wrong or we're not exactly how you
wanted them to turn out and now then
people come to you and start talking to
you about you know Google AdWords or
whatever and you're like God you know I
sure and you're gun-shy and so you know
exactly what you need to get over or
what the prices and so it's a lesson
yeah yeah
and you know initially when we were
talking about marketing you were talking
about billboards and how you didn't want
to buy one billboard and there was like
a frequency that you thought was really
important in order to get consumers to
sort of resonates a brand or think
it when you were setting your marketing
campaign when you're setting your
marketing budget our campaigns do you
think okay we're gonna allocate this
much to digital this much out-of-home
this much to you know b2b or are you
sort of like look this is a living
organism and we'll call the play when we
sort of walk up to the line so we
currently divide our marketing out into
branded marketing adults as well as
direct to consumer and so some company
is actually having especially when
you're small you have one person who's
maybe you know kind of yeah sure kind of
being or running the ad buys or whatever
they're actually two very separate you
know departments in terms of in terms of
budgets but what we found is the more
money we put into direct-to-consumer as
an example in terms of ads like there's
a lot of people who will go on Facebook
or you know or other other places where
we may show up and they're gonna walk
into a Target store or they're gonna go
on the you know they're gonna go on an
insta part or whatever an order and so
that for us we've just found it you know
there's some carryover into the branded
or sort of the offline stuff that
they're gonna do they may not click the
button and actually order online or you
know if they see TV they may you know
again go into their local grocery store
or you know whatever they they you know
might end up doing that so I think it's
it's just a matter of there's definitely
spillover into that so it's it's a you
know I would say that from a from the
standpoint of budgets are
direct-to-consumer just because of its
measure ability and because of the
spillover we put more money into that
but you know it on the on the flip side
of that too we viewed the Superbowl ad
as there was no you know at the end it
said direct it said Dre Kim calm but
there was no 800 number or nobody's
going on don't know if Superbowl to go
by but you know the next time that they
saw a direct-to-consumer ad
did they click it because they remember
of course yeah and you know and so
that's that's really how we you know how
we view it and if the direct consumer
side is sort of larger than the branded
side it's Facebook like a native
Facebook was king there and I think
you've told other people as well
Facebook is King therefore hint as well
is that right is that where you say okay
this is our yeah yeah definitely I would
say I would say from you know third
party like companies where we're doing
doing it we're also you know we do we
also you know go out to other lists as
well and and do you know different swaps
with other companies as well to try and
figure out if we can you know email
people and do some sort of partnership
too so we've done you know it's it's
funny to just from a branded standpoint
and again sort of I can't say that I was
strategically like you know brilliance
or you know knew exactly what was going
to happen but a few years ago
Verizon reached out to me and they're
like hey you know we've got this ad
we're asking entrepreneurs to be a part
of this ad would you be interested and
I've been a Verizon customer since
pretty much since day one I wouldn't get
in cell connection through you know ATT
sorry ATT but I'm sure they've got a lot
better but it was but it was just I've
just always been Verizon and and that
was from my well days and I was
traveling around a lot and so I still
have my nine one seven number even
though I'm living in the Bay Area and so
they asked me to be a part of this and
they didn't really give me a sort of
clear definition of what it would be and
they told me to show up in this like
studio and I really thought it was going
to be print and then after they did the
print they were like by the way we think
we're gonna run this and they they
actually didn't run the ad until
recently and so it's running on CNN like
a lot right now and by some miracle they
were just talking to me just like you
and I were talking about some miracle I
had a quote that they picked up on which
is part of the Verizon
and it said you don't have to be
together to work together and so that
has become a Verizon like quote and it
says cure gold and founder and CEO of
hint and but the number every time that
Verizon ad runs people go on to our site
yeah definitely it doesn't say drinking
concert it's very subtle and then the
exact same thing happened with a company
called NetSuite and I was speaking at
you know their their conference and you
know I tell the story that I truly
didn't know how to call Oracle to we
were like moving out of QuickBooks and
you know I didn't know how to call
Oracle I just thought where would I
start and I'd heard about NetSuite and
and you know I just thought they're like
maybe eventually we'll get to Oracle but
for now like let's let's start with
these guys at NetSuite and so we've you
know grown with them we told them all
their problems that they had and and we
continue to grow and the CMO said to me
you know I loved watching you on stage
like you're just you know telling the
story and and would you do this ad for
us and I was like sure and so so that ad
has now been running for a year and
every single time that ad runs it's like
you know hint people go to have water
duck yeah sure yeah and so we have not
spent a dime on that advertising and you
know we we have you know I would say
it's I would say conservatively between
Verizon and NetSuite which is now an
Oracle company easily 50 million dollars
and adds that they will that's crazy in
our brain I certainly seen a lot more
like businesses doing that like I've
seen a senior at first on like that
sweet it's fantastic I've seen
shipstation doing ads with a beard brand
I've seen like Amazon doing ads with
companies like not pods
it's really amazing to see these large
business or its business has sort of
leaning into that I feel like it all
started with American Express a long
time ago and I've done some for American
Express to you I mean I think that I've
learned I've done it for some of their
direct mail pieces I haven't done a
television commercial
but I think like that's you know the
other thing that I say to entrepreneurs
it's like you know none of those were
intentional partnerships but they're
they're authentic and they're real and I
think that you know when you're out
that's why I always tell entrepreneurs
like the sooner you can get out and
actually tell your story to and that
doesn't mean like necessarily like
talking to press outlets about it I mean
maybe it does but also actually speaking
and whether that's you know at whatever
the hustle or shorter grind or whatever
you go you know it you go and speak at
some of these conferences and you start
telling your story about like we
initially funded the company with our
American Express card and thank God we
had like good credit yeah and because we
needed it and you know to buy the
bottles and the cabinets and then you
know American Express reached out like
took them six months so they reached out
and they're like we want to talk to you
about the story and thank you for being
a customer and then suddenly you know it
was clear that they wanted to get you
involved and so those things are you
know so valuable like if you can figure
out two or three partnerships that you
have where you know you just really
believe I mean again like you know I had
another phone company reach out to me
after the Verizon one and I was like you
know I just I wouldn't do like I
wouldn't do another food company I
wouldn't do you know but I I just
thought like these are these are
companies that I truly believe in and
and I think like if you can borrow
equity from those brands because they're
clearly borrowing equity from our grant
right we're startup we're a female
founded startup like there's lots of
reasons why I don't bring you products
yeah 21st century completely agree that
they're do that is marketing and I'm
just saying like that that is one where
I think nobody's really thought like I
mean we've we value those relationships
and you know like that is so big and and
it doesn't cost you any money yeah it's
company money yeah and so that's that's
amazing yeah I'd love to talk a little
bit about the other categories that
you've launched into uh early on we
talked about hint water boat that was
I'm not sure if you call it flat water
or like non-carbonated carbonated still
water so still water carbonated you know
hint fizz we talked about caffeinated
since then you've also launched a couple
other categories I know you've launched
hints sunscreen which smells absolutely
amazing it's a spray sunscreen
I think you've launched nto ruin as well
are there other categories that are sort
of coming up and how did you think about
those cash you know for us I think you
know it was this it was really again
looking at how can we help the consumer
get healthy right and we felt like there
were a lot of consumers who were coming
to us who were drinking our product and
they would you know reach out and say
hey you know what kind of you know
makeup should I wear or what we were
like wait what like we're water you know
that's what we're doing and and so we've
we felt like we could start to touch on
you know these these categories that
were in our opinion and not doing what
you know we needed or what our consumer
needed and so I'm allergic to coconut
and so a lot of the you know natural
units that are out there have coconut
yeah and in them and so for me like I
was totally on board with the concept of
a natural deodorant but I wanted
something you know free coconut oil
right and so that was something that you
know I just started to play around with
the home and then I just thought huh
this is really interesting and then you
know for us to it's primarily sold
online I mean we were and you know on
Amazon as well as on drinking calm but
you know for us it's really helped us to
kind of understand this consumer a
little bit more and what more they would
be interested in as well I mean we we I
and I think the same is true with the
sunscreen I mean sunscreen was way
harder than
actually we embarked on it I mean you
need FDA approval you're like I mean we
use you know we're using the same
essences that we're using in in the
water for the sunscreen which you know
they actually needed to do the FTA
needed to do shelf-life testing when we
ended up before we actually got the
approval because most companies use
fragrances they don't actually which is
a whole other topic and you're using
natural essences well yeah I mean and it
was like it was crazy I mean that we
were like what I saw in the beauty and
personal care industry was so much
further behind than what the food
industry what what people were talking
about and so but we were one of the
first companies non mineral based
sunscreens that was really calling out
oxybenzone and so there's and so I
really believed I had you know some
pre-cancer stuff on my nose that
wouldn't go away and I started you know
really looking deeper at the sunscreen
industry and you know I had grown up in
Arizona have red hair way too much Sun
early on and I had read about the stuff
oxybenzone and I was like you know this
stuff is really bad I mean there's the
Center for Disease Control back in the
late 70s that actually told the FDA that
that oxybenzone may actually enhance pre
cancer cell growth and they had
recommended to the FDA not to approve it
and somehow it got approved and so
there's many places in the world where
oxybenzone is not approved but in the
u.s. it is approved and so you know we
started calling it out and and I think
for me this goes back to sort of like
the big company strategy the number of
people after we launched it from large
companies who reached out to me and said
hey you know we've always known that
this oxybenzone stuff is not so great
but it's hard because we have
all brands that are housed in our house
and for us to actually call out that
means we have to reformulate everything
to show you and so like that's really
tough and so I was like okay well you
know we'll just keep doing that right
well we'll keep calling it out and so
eventually you know you'll have time to
go and reformulate or not and you will
just have more runway to just go and
build your company and so you know
that's the thing that I also realized
that I had done with hint water which
was you know we really focused on
ingredients and and you know that the
ingredient was sweetener right if doc
man look and then you start to look at
the rest of the product and you know all
the great stuff around it but I think
it's no different for products to and
more and more I think people are you
know looking at their products it's not
just about being organic or not organic
it's really about people are getting
smart about ingredients yeah I think you
know I was speaking to on an interview
earlier this morning and I was talking
about you know the world today and and
what is the biggest thing that I've
noticed and I think that you know for
the last few weeks since we've been in
shelter-in-place I mean the number of
conversations that I've had with people
not only you know friends of mine but
also business colleagues around health
like people are realizing you know the
health is is like such a key thing and
everything yeah right it's everything
right and so and and I think that you
know people are trying to you know make
sure that they're getting their exercise
every day but then also eating right and
eating well and I have not heard this
conversation like you know everywhere
where I go like I'm hearing it now yeah
I mean people are just so focused on it
which is perfect there been have there
been first I I think that's absolutely
true and I think you're right and I
think like we'll have that conversation
a lot more when the Kobe crisis sort of
dies down because right now I think it's
a struggle in order to make sure your
fridge is stocked and in a way that you
know where you can get food in a easy
healthy safe way yeah
once it becomes easy again it'll be a
lot more important to people
are there other beverage companies that
have sort of crossed this Rubicon and
gotten into personal care yeah look I
I'm trying to think of other beverage
companies that have launched personal
care products do you know of any you
know I feel like vitamin water or way
back when did I mean chopsticks we had
always had like a great lip balm or
chapstick or whatever you want to call
it so but I you know I don't I don't
really know I know of any others that
that really crossed over I mean I think
like the challenge of course is that the
soda you know companies like I mean look
most we are today the largest
independent non-alcoholic beverage in
the country that doesn't have a
relationship with Coke Pepsi or dr.
peppers now so I think like you know a
lot of companies and a lot of founders
that I've talked to I mean they could
not figure out to do what we've done
nationwide without you know the trucks
the coke trucks or the Pepsi absolutely
no one beyond ten million you know it's
like I mean beverages are just like
sunscreens are heard beverages are
harder I mean beverages are you know you
have to like when you go into major
markets in addition to the Cisco's and
the UNF eyes and all the rest of it you
have to have you know a DSD Network that
is going into these stores every day
that make sure that your shelves aren't
wiped out and if you you know if you
don't know that now if you're starting a
beverage like you learn it really
quickly whatever I'm sure focused on you
know the 7-elevens of the world or or
whatever you cannot rely on the stores
no matter what category they're in
whether it's club or whatever you have
to have teams of people that are you
know in those stores and actually
helping to build out K stacks and and do
you know in merchandise and make sure
that your reorders or you'll fail and so
that's why you know the teams are bigger
it's sort of you know it's just what
ends up happening and so I think when I
look at these other categories too it's
it's
probably tougher to build the sunscreen
and you know and we really haven't put a
whole lot of marketing into any of this
here I mean we're really sort of in the
infancy stages of it
but I think it's for us it's really I
mean it's not take any more people to do
it I mean we've got like a small group
inside internally that can focus on it
because it's just it's not as high touch
as beverages you think it's a little bit
like giving people haven't done it as
much in the past because they're afraid
of like you know coca doesn't want to
buy a deodorant business or a chapstick
business or do you think it they're
afraid of dilution of brand or do you
think they just haven't had the right
story they haven't been focused on
ingredients or do you think it's just
because you know people haven't thought
of it or like is there a reason that
hasn't done that sir no I think there's
definitely people have said you know
you're starting these categories and you
know the soda companies like won't like
that when they're looking at you to you
know to buy but I think that there's
there's two things that I would say
number one you know my my goal is not to
figure out like how to get my company
perfect so that really Pepsi will buy us
right we have we have built a standalone
company that is now profitable that has
grown every single year for the last 15
years
I mean we've built this really solid
company and I think in addition to that
we have a direct-to-consumer business
that is I don't think there's any other
you know company in our space that is
doing what we're doing offline as well
as online and I think soon people are
these large brands are going to figure
out that you know hint is a brand name
that can stretch across multiple
categories I mean I would love to do a
home product not necessarily to go you
know super broad on it but just to
actually figure out because I'm all I'm
all about consumer
permission to and and you know and I
think unless you test it you just don't
really know you know and whether or not
and and I think there's I see products
every single day where I'm like if it
just had that or like just be a little
bit better and for me it's just really
trying to understand you know when we
talk about lifetime value I mean that's
just extra bands the lifetime value of a
consumer and if you can if you can do
that in a way that doesn't jeopardize
the rest of your sales that doesn't you
know get get your team focused on stuff
that they shouldn't be focused on then
it makes sense and and I don't think it
happens like I wouldn't go launch a
company today and go into multiple
categories yeah definitely say but we
gotten super permission to do that yeah
and the consumer and and I don't think I
would have even like had the you know
courage to go do it if I didn't keep
hearing from the consumer help me
you like help me just like you I have a
coconut allergy just like you I had read
about oxybenzone you know you should go
you should go do this you should go do
this so I not only feel like with our
products we're helping consumers but I
also feel like we're helping large
companies really understand that this
consumer like wants health right and
they're no longer going to be fooled by
you know these words like diet or you
know natural or oxybenzone or like
feeling like it's a you know plus it's
like it's like these these things are
engineering our health and and I think
that you know that is the time we stand
up to that we we stand up to it and I
fundamentally believe it every single
day that that's what we're doing and if
and if there's products that I think we
can do better you know I don't plan on
having this company under my leadership
be the next you know honest company the
Jessica Alba's honest you know not the
honesty that I just I
don't think we need to do thousands and
thousands of skews I think what we need
to do is do a few skews well and really
try and understand where the consumer
you know wants us to go yeah
what kara we're way over time I really
appreciate you spending the time I'm
gonna ask you a bunch of just really
quick forward quick questions one what
is the best-selling flavor of mint water
it's a close tie between blackberry and
watermelon okay what is your favorite
flavor of mint water uh we just launched
Clementine Clementine that's certain
favor right now
amazing yeah okay cherry cherry fizz is
also I'm okay when you aren't drinking
hint water what do you drink it coffee
so I'm a coffee snob I love you waiter
coffee another San Francisco great
female founded brand so I'm very uh yeah
I would say you know coffee and finally
if somebody is um wants to start a
beverage brand today what do you
recommend and the first thing they do to
get into a brick-and-mortar store is is
it just trying to go into bodegas in New
York is it to try and get a you know a
meeting with your local Whole Foods
buyer is it to try and get a booth at
Expo West what is the first step that
they should think of when they're like
I've got a beverage brand or a food
brand I want or beverage brand let's
focus on beverage brands I have a
beverage friend I want to get this into
brick-and-mortar stores what's the first
step there I think it's finding who
you're on dances because I I think that
if you don't you know if you're
launching an energy drink and a whatever
22 ounce can that you know that's
probably not the market for Whole Foods
I mean maybe maybe not it depends on the
ingredients but I think you just need to
find out who your market is and then and
then you know go and try and get in
there I mean when I got into hold 15
years ago they had a program where you
could actually go in to the local store
and try and sell it in and they would
test it out I'm not sure since am
acquire them whether or not they're
doing that or not
but you know don't focus on the targets
or the Costco's I mean start small and
just keep doing well and just keep
building and building a building and
then I would say also you know social
having social channels has just become
you know absolutely critical and if you
can you know do that right I think that
that's the most important thing and
whether that's you know figuring out who
influencers are you know there's there's
highs and lows and pluses and minuses to
that but I think also just you know are
you doing something from a messaging
standpoint that you think an audience
would really relate to yeah that that
you know they would tap into and I think
you know don't be afraid I know many
days you actually you know delivered
cases and you were you know at the trade
shows and and showing up I think it's
it's a you know I still see handi you
know not necessarily delivering javonni
you know everywhere but every once in a
while you know showing up and and
definitely at the trade shows and Daniel
from kind bar as well and and I think
it's like never be afraid to you know
take care of your product and and make
sure that it's being cared for and yeah
that's the biggest thing fantastic
thanks so much Gareth people want to
hear more from you where should they
like where should they here where should
they follow you should it be is it on
Instagram it's it on Twitter can you
provide you yeah I mean I'm on all
social channels at carat golden kar a
gol di n I'm probably most active on
Twitter and have a pretty robust
audience there that's lots of fun and
and so yeah that that would probably be
the biggest place and then if you are
interested in buying hinted at stores
but also on our site at drinking calm as
well as Amazon fantastic thanks so much
for your time John really appreciate it
this is fantastic
awesome
[Music]